it's Tuesday februari twenty-third and  Far Cry primal has just released and  even though it's day one some players  have already dug up some really cool  secrets you to barona zombies posted  videos of himself finding some Easter  eggs that reference Assassin's Creed and  far cry 3 blood dragon DLC Ubisoft  properties all around the Assassin's  Creed reference happens in a cutscene  where one caveman performs a classic  leap of faith it's been suggested that  all ubisoft games take place in the same  universe so this may very well be the  creation of the signature move as for  blood dragon you can find a cave  containing one of the titular dragons  skeletons lit up by neon and you'll get  an achievement for your discovery we  gave Far Cry primal an 8 out of 10 in  Easter eggs like this or why we love it  you can check out tons of gameplay and  coverage on gamespot and for all the Far  Cry assassin's creed or Ubisoft news you  need you're definitely in the right  place